[Music]
in zoophile love news zoo phones on a
[ __ ] elephant so into my love from
the land of Ikea oh I love how do you
say hello in Sweden's all right
a man who previously had sex with a
dolphin reviewed the movie shape of
water he's credible now nobody should
talk about this movie unless they [ __ ] a
dolphin he's like take it from me and if
he funk a dollar to the dolphin [ __ ] him
as a question that's a good question
Danny [ __ ] the blowhole or did he [ __ ]
the dolphin vagina or did the dolphin
[ __ ] Oh Davidson yeah there's so much I
just might answer your question yes
please
well before we got there I just want to
show you guys I can't give you my
opinions without facts there is a clip
here of shape of water oh that was gonna
be the dolphin [ __ ] no I don't have
that there we go
just so you guys familiarize yourself
not like this movie here we go
if I told you about her
what would I say perhaps I would just
warn you about the tale of love and loss
and the monster who tried to destroy it
all
[Music]
if I spoke about it
well when I tell you all right so it's a
movie about the fact that this character
Eliza
falls in love with this no creature no
it's a movie about it's a troll movie I
think the greatest troll movie probably
ever executed on the American race and
the world about a woman who [ __ ] a sea
monster and that's a fact
mm-hmm and the sea monsters like this
he's basically aid from Hellboy like
Lily is seen yes sir they got the same
[ __ ] suit he has it same like Lego
[ __ ] about it is this doesn't have the
goggles on that's why it when it you
know shape of water I'm legit thought it
was a prequel or like a spin-off of
Hellboy right I mean that's a from
Hellboy give me a [ __ ] break dude
he's like what if I just had eight from
help with like [ __ ] a chick and fall
in love and like treat it seriously is
he also eating rotten eggs because I
want to know that's true that's true
I like shape of water was great same
powers too he likes the water and like
he has like some kind of mental powers
of some [ __ ] some people don't like to
believe in miracles the fact that this
won Best Picture is the greatest troll I
think that has ever been pulled I
thought the picture was really nice this
actress she's probably like what some
French actress from Juilliard or
something that [ __ ] was old she got
naked completely naked against a man in
a sea monster costume that they kept
having to wet down before the scene yep
I mean tell me that's not amazing it's
great she [ __ ] masturbated a tub
every morning that's all you ever
[ __ ] talk about that's the only scene
I know about this movie because you've
said it 10 times it's revolutionary all
right so this is Malcolm J Brenner
that's his girlfriend he's bluffin [ __ ]
whoa whoa so you [ __ ] this dog my name
dogs often looks very happy back in the
70s
what a [ __ ] when he worked in this
now closed amusement park in Florence
this is what this guy identifies as a
dog that's [ __ ] gross
dolphin identifies as humans okay this
guy have like have like posters of
dolphins on his wall at home like next
to a pool table [ __ ] like a dolphin
calendar like a dolphin like like
jumping out of a buzz in water that
could not that's not comfortable [ __ ]
in water
yeah the most comfortable thing I've
ever done hearted you would be water
with loopings a lot better wouldn't it
[ __ ] [ __ ] and disgusting he [ __ ]
like [ __ ] tone company yeah finding
that [ __ ] out with the dog yeah maybe
they [ __ ] they [ __ ] in a pool of
Bay oil oh that that.oh animal cruelty
well the dolphin kept its head above it
it can't breathe it has a bucket of
water around the gills but it's in baby
oil veggie jacks off to those dolphin
sleep sounds yeah like what somebody is
rolling around a [ __ ] like creaky
little shopping cart gets horny Yeah
right
he's like what was that dolly somebody
starts [ __ ] hey where'd that come
from [ __ ] cleaning a window alright
so here leads back in 2010 he releases
autobiographical novel called [ __ ] the
dolphin what god oh damn
wet goddess oh my god
I got dropped and I thought that [ __ ]
was a mermaid I preferred it was a
dolphin but damn that [ __ ] was good or
like how to make love with the dolphin
would be great oh yeah yeah with him
like with a cigar and a smoking jacket
yeah and it hurt the wetsuit that's kind
of open with a lot come on bro a wetsuit
with a [ __ ] dick open like let like
part where you put his dick huh flex
Allah what does a dolphin [ __ ] look
like it's a slit like oh wow slow down
while you say it was later he was also
the subject of an award-winning
documentary called dolphin lover
award-winning huh yeah this documentary
was an award-winning dog okay so how he
raped the dolphin no so he claims that
dolly seduced him shut the [ __ ] oh you
rejected her yeah a lot of time out of
hand yeah but uh she kept putting up
pushing angry so this is what he said
she would rub her genital slit against
me and if I tried to push her away she
would get very angry with me when she
wanted to masturbate on my foot and I
wouldn't let her she threw herself on
top of me and push me down to the 12
foot bottom of the pool so that time you
said that he got subdued or like that
she said I mean he can't stay on land
yeah you know so unless she just got up
on her fin boom maybe she just started
wildly with Jess she was like she was
like he can get the [ __ ] out of the pool
yeah right well you know what that's
that's so that's so [ __ ] gender
[ __ ] up because like that's what
that's what happens to girls all the
time like you could leave at any time
so this is the same [ __ ] you could've
left at any time but don't blame the
victim a guy who who's a dolphin makes
him hard I think has some issues that
are deeper mmm yeah so this love affair
last little while no yeah me cheated on
his wife with a dolphin I don't know
what is he a [ __ ] dolphin trainer at
SeaWorld and [ __ ] a guy who says the
dolphin came on to me is not is not
married what
uh what's his name Malcolm Malcolm
Brandon if you're known as the dolphin
[ __ ] guy you're not married definitely
not close enough the dolphin tank hold
on guys I'm gonna be in for a couple of
hours why Malcolm no it's a picture with
a dolphin if this guy was our friend
all we would talk about and clown him on
him about is how he [ __ ] about yeah we
feed him to know we'd be [ __ ] up my
girl here suppose she want to [ __ ] it he
also mention he [ __ ] his dog too and
he the dog come on Tim to dad that was
just hot to animal he needs to go [ __ ] a
real Beastmaster he needs to go this is
a grizzly man I'm like this guy wants to
[ __ ] a bear this guy is [ __ ]
disgusting I want to see him strapped to
a chair and give him some viagra and
just have different types of animals
walk by him only see what happened to
give him viagra for them cuz I wanted to
be already like throbbing and he can't
resist and he'd be strapped in wait so
he's already like in it's erotic state
of mind and then just have like little
monkeys what if what if he's like the
Brad Pitt to animals like and in your
experiment the [ __ ] giraffe comes and
starts sucking on his dick and [ __ ] and
then leaves and a [ __ ] monkey cutter
that would be the [ __ ] longest head
bomb ever dude a bucket giraffe draft a
draft would be like don't tell me about
big dicks they don't exist yes they do
he does say that they finally he finally
consummated their relationship
he was vertical like she was hurt
horizontal anyway so their relationship
lasted a while and so he was saying he
got interviewed by Huffington Post he
broke up with who oh so the dolphin
dumped him after a 36 she was sent to an
aquarium in Mississippi where she later
died of a heart break right button man
man my dude information on where he was
[ __ ] this dolphin like was it like a
babe they met like I'll meet you at 3:00
p.m. at the Florida Keys and [ __ ]
so that's why earlier I mentioned that
he was doing this at a theme park that
is now closed in Florida see he would go
there to take photos for a book about
the dolphin show and that's how do you
happen he came a-courtin i don't know
how he was left alone there because if I
saw a journalist that's pantsless inside
the dolphin dolphin I'd probably see
that at the zoo naked guy with the
[ __ ] camera on his wagon yeah he's
taking pictures of the dolphins
underwater right yeah I mean that's how
he's very good yeah so he's gonna have a
wetsuit just from the waist up he's
thinking with yeah it is biggest as
begley he's [ __ ] gross I see him and
I want to [ __ ] get rid of this life
so interesting how can he was saying
that there is a distinct difference
between like bestiality people and then
Zoo files what's the difference what the
[ __ ] is the different comments here
before getting in the water and after he
got the water what do you like light up
a cigarette like the real question is
how do you end up in water is still a
greasy ass fun yeah he does yeah well
let me tell you the distinction though
so he's saying that beefy alles that
they just they just have sex with the
animal and then walk away but the zoo
file the cuddle laughter do the red ones
he says he they're the real weird love
that is the question oh god if he [ __ ]
an ape is that bestiality or is it only
thing it still beast yeah oh really it's
pretty close to humans very close but
still very far yeah yeah if I fought the
chimpanzee it's no record about what
about the will say I [ __ ] some girls
are you could qualify as chimpanzees
there it is what would you what about
the gorillas that speak urgently as my
name is Coco either way I talk you know
I don't know cuz like [ __ ] a girl is
like [ __ ] a football player dude cuz
I just picture the gorillas grabbing
can't explore
chimp and the chimpanzee to the Frog and
he just bow-bow-bow boom tosses beside
so who [ __ ] who that's true who [ __ ]
- yeah cuz I've been seeing some [ __ ]
Amazonian lady porn and I'm like damn
dude these girls are like six five and
the guys are like five three and then
they don't even spread their legs when
they do it the guy has his legs spread
it's like it's like dominance porn and
stuff and then she's like doing him what
are you talking about he has his wiener
in her butt his legs are spread like
this and her legs are closed and she's
doing the thrusting and she's carrying
him making like ride it's crazy I'm
kicking off for show Amazonian born
where she's thrusting into him and he's
not just thinking I don't like this
stuff I know it's off so much to give us
[ __ ] different positions high
differences you gave us too many details
alright but see this is that this is why
I like him he doesn't know that he
doesn't like something until he tries it
and that is I love this like three hours
of research then yeah yeah like I'm not
gonna know if I hate acting a joke
hey you know how much chocolate cake I
ate before I said I don't like chocolate
I still do it today buddy I'm not a big
fan of chocolate but maybe this one all
like and then you know what I found out
I like dark chocolate oh okay yeah
[Music]